[Musique]
dans les années 40 il y avait un concept
très proche de celui de la salsa celui
de la latine
musique
[Musique]
si le nom de salsa est né aux États-Unis
il n reste pas moins que les racines de
cette musique se trouvent à
Cuba c la plus grande de toutes les
Antilles peup par des descends d'esclav
africain espagol de travailleurs chinois
et irlandais d'Haïtiens et de français
de Jamaïcains d'indiens et de nombreux
peuples encore et le berceau d'une
culture riche et dynamique toujours
[Musique]
innovante ce métissage créatif qui se
voit sur les visages des Cubains
s'entend par-dessus tout dans leur
musique qui n'a jamais cessé d'être un
mélange une sauce toujours renouvelée et
remise au goût du jour mais pourtant
toujours identique à
[Musique]
elle-même
du son montouno au son urbain des années
20 en passant par le mambo et le
Cha en intégrant tour à tour certains
éléments du jazz du funk du Ré et même
du rap en puisant au sources de la rouba
de la ConA et des complexes ryth cubain
la salsa cubaine est aujourd'hui encore
le creuset d'où sortent les groupes les
plus novateur et les musiciens les plus
inventifs en matière de
salsa
[Musique]
miraante la
década dans an il y a une grande
population latine aux États-Unis de nos
jours elle comporte plus de 22 millions
d'habitants et il développe un besoin de
suppl à toute une série de goû esthétiqu
lié à leur
[Musique]
identité en
1970 Fania lance un documentaire pour
promouvoir le talent artistique de ses
musicien et je suppose que ça a dû être
Johnny P qui a sugéré à la firme de
l'appeler
salsa compte surtout d'une nouvelle
sonorité et d'une nouvelle façon plus
moderne plus actualisée d'aborder cette
musique qui était enraciné dans les
traditions de la Caraïbe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hispanique maintenant nous utilisons ce
terme parce que ce terme est si
généralisé que tu ne peux pas te fâcher
avec tout le monde et dire à tout le
monde que c'est ceci et cela parce que
maintenant les gens connaissent ça comme
salsa parce que la promotion a eu ce
pouvoir là mais à chaque fois que nous
avons l'opportunité de clarifier les
choses nous clarifions mais si tu
cherches ce qu la salsa dans un
dictionnaire de musique tu verras que ce
genre musical n'existe
pas
[Musique]
CRE
lacanor je crois que le majeur
rapprochement de cette musique s fait
avec un genre musical très ancien vers
la fin du 18e et le début du 19e siècle
dans la zone la plus orientale de Cuba
et qui se connaissait sous le nom de son
de son
cubain le son suite à son développement
dans le milieu rural avait envahi les
villes et par-dessus tout la capitale La
Havane jusque dans les années
20 à partir de là il a commencé à se
diffuser sous une forme appelée sonne
urbain vers le reste du pays et vers
l'extérieur y hacia
fuera mamá yo quiero saber de dónde son
los
cant lo encuentro
muero
[Musique]
conprender de dóe
serán
dans le son on trouve les instruments à
cord de pincée ainsi les espagnol
apportèrent la mandoline le laod et
surtout ils apportèrent la guitare la
guitare a généré de nouveau instruments
comme le charango dans la zone andine le
Quatro au Venezuela et le 1 à
Cuba le 13 à Cuba se caractérise
fondamentalement par le fait que ce
n'est pas un instrument
harmonique c'est un instrument à cord de
pincée qui fonctionne mélodiquement et
rythmiquement d'autre part dans le sonne
on trouve le
bongo et le bongo est ici une
transformation des tambours africains de
telle façon que le système de frappe du
tambour avec la main
persiste et non celui de la frappe avec
une
baguette comme les Européens en avaient
généralement l'habitude ce qui permet
d'obtenir plusieurs
timbres avec le bongo ou avec tout autre
tambour qui se joue avec la main selon
la position du coup on obtient un timbre
[Musique]
différent dans le son apparaissent des
instruments
comme les marac postérieurement les
claves apparaissent des instruments en
relation avec la base harmonique qui
n'avait pas le concept harmonique
européen mais le concept percutif
africain comme c'est le cas pour la
Marim Boula dont les ancêtres en tant
qu'instrument sont en
Afrique ce sont les mas des groupes
bantou appelés aussi
Samas
eso me está combinando si usted no sabe
bailar solire sobr levando La Palma la
parte un Rayo tiene ditil estremece La
Palma la parte un Rayo tiene viento y
estremece y a mí cuando me parece de
Pollo me vuelvo Gallo y a M parece de
Pollo me vuelvo Gallo a gozar mujeres
andoo primer novia que tuve
ella
[Musique]
ci la Primer no
queve
[Musique]
après le
Moyen-ge e l'tion du discours musical
sur la
fincept africain est totalement
différent la fin n'est pas du tout
importante pour
l'Africain c'est le début qui est
important le
soliste le son expose le motif de son
chant et chante tout un texte comme si
c'était une
chanson la seconde partie est appelée
montunho le soliste prend une phrase du
texte qu'il a chanté la met dans le cœur
qu'ilomagne et commence à improviser et
le cœur lui
répond il improvise le cœur répond il
improvise le cœur
répond et il unit alors la conception
d'ensemble fermé de
l'Européen avec la conception d'ensemble
ouvert de
l'Africain
caric camina si vaado cam por la madrug
Camando va
cam
C Camando mercado Camando la Plaza cam
por la madug
cam
[Musique]
190 en 1920 existe à La Havane les sex
de son qui ét venu des petites villes du
pays et de la zone rurale vers la
capitale dans la capitale c'est sex de
son rencontrent les groupes qui jou du
jazz de façon stridente provenant
fondamentalement de la nouvelle
orléande ce qui at le plus l'attion dans
les groupes de jazz la trompette à elle
est passé dans les son cubains à tel
point que les sex de son ont disparu et
que s formé le premier se le
National et ensuite touteses
imitations le National d'O po existe
encore de jeunes musiciens ont remplacé
les plus vieux et le groupe continue à
faire danser les amoureux du son de tous
[Musique]
à Cuba les retraités ne sont pas les
moins alertes bien au
contraire la grâce et l'élégance de leur
pas forc
l'admiration c'est que la danse est
inséparable de la salsa elle vit autant
que la musique dans le corps des
Cubains le groupe a été fondé en 1926 le
avril de ce fait il vient d'avoir 70 ans
ça fait un sacré bout de temps par la
suite le groupe a assimilé le son qui a
cette époque était en pleine
apogé ils ont commencé depuis les années
20 alors eux les fondateurs ils on
organis le groupe un groupe de jeunes
qui se sont donnés pour Tage de sentir
ce qu'ils entendaient dans les disques
de l'époque le
[Musique]
son
a
[Musique]
a yo
soy y se acabó a
M
a
a yo soy
tri
[Applaudissements]
yur sol se
divert y decía se acabó a M qu a qu a qu
a M qu
a
a a
M
a a M qué Nena más mala a M qué eres
compa a M qué eres a
M
a
[Musique]
a le problème vientit que les artistes
cubains qui sonttis les pays étrangers
ont cherché une façon de subsister avec
notre
musique avec la musique qu'ils ont
appris dans notre Cuba dans notre Cuba
de
toujours c'est-à-dire que cette musique
qui naî qui fait vibrer n'importe quelle
personne eux l'ont prise dans certains
cas ils ont modifié quelques instruments
mais c'était notre
sonne si vous avez la possibilité de
mettre la main sur un disque d'arsenio
Rodriguez analysezle et vous verrez en
comparant avec aujourd'hui de la même
chose Arsenio maintient l'ancienneté
stylistique mais incorpore de nouveaux
instruments de nouvelles sonorités pour
former ce que sera définitivement par la
suite l'ensemble
[Musique]
cubain
les vieilles chansons des années 30 et
40 ne sont pas passé de mode à Cuba et
continue à être chanté joué et dansé par
toutes les générations aussi bien à la
dans les campagnes les plus
[Musique]
reculé
losantes plustit
émerveilléstifour du son à force
d'imiter les pas des adultes ils seront
très vite danser aussi bien queux
frapper le rythme de base et qui sait
jouer d'un
[Musique]
instrument
que los
encuentroantes y los quiero conocer con
susas
fascinantes
[Musique]
laseroendti
la
[Musique]
beaucoup de musiciens cubains ont ainsi
appris leur art et certains sont même de
véritables autodidacte de
[Musique]
génie c'est ici dans la région
deenosé en
1919 it appelé plus tard el Barbaro del
ritmo selon la légende l'aïu de
barartolomoré dit béni aurait été un
prince du Congo capturé à l'âge de 9 ans
et réduit en
[Musique]
esclavage c'est en tout cas dans le plus
grand dénuement que grandit benim
Moré excellent élève il dut arrêter
l'école très tôt pour travailler et
aider sa
famille à l'âge de 6 ans il connaissait
c'est déjà un nombre impressionnant de
chansons par cœur battait le rythme avec
tout ce qui lui tombait sous la main
jouait de la guitare et dansait
merveilleusement il montait des
orchestres avec des boîtes de lait
concentré dont il faisait des Bongo avec
des cuillères dont il faisait des claves
et chantait tout en dirigeant ses
musiciens qui n'étaient entre autres que
ses frères et
sœurs
[Musique]
parti à La Havane pour vendre des fruits
il s'improvisa à 20 ans chanteur de
[Musique]
rue il finit par être remarqué grâce à
une émission
[Musique]
radio
Benny était un grand musicien qui
n'avait jamais fait d'études académiques
il faisait les arrangements par
intuition il disait à chacun ce qu'il
devait faire il montait et ça sonnait
fabuleusement
bien c'était naturel parce qu'il ne
savait pas il n'a jamais été à une école
de musique il n'a jamais été à rien tout
ça lui tout seul céit
naturel benimoré naî dans le village de
Las il était d'origine paysane
voyez-vous il a travaillé dans toutes
sortes de choses et pourtant il avait
depuis qu'il était petit une vocation
pour le chant et pour la musique en
général et bennyoré a été aussi en
contact avec beaucoup de sociétés
afroocubaines quand il est sorti et
qu'il s'est consacré uniquement à la
musique il est tout de suite passé de
Sian fuegos à La
Havane là il a eu la chance de s'unir je
vais dire à l'un des meilleurs trios qui
était à cette époque un sept le trio
Matamoros dirigé par le célèbre musicien
cubain Miguel
Matamoros quand benimoré s'est intégré à
l'ensemble Matamoros il a voyagé au
Mexique où il s'est alors uni à un autre
célèbre musicien cubain qui était en
train de lancer un nouveau rythme à
cette
époque c'était perz
Prado grâce à per Prado il a appris le
mambo mais à travers le mambo quelque
chose de plus
important Prado d'abord ben ensuite
concevait la musique avec des formats
instrumentaux des orchestres ou
orchestration qui n'étai pas
traditionnell ni typique des Caraïbes
mais qui était typique et traditionnel
de la musique nordaméricaine du moment
la banda giganté de Benny Mor avait la
même structure que les Jazz Band de Glen
Miller et de Benny Goodman à la même
[Musique]
époque
ene
su que ya la gente andciendo
queundendo una
era ya lo
sabesanga va
[Musique]
empezar
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les années 50 à Cuba voi éclore le
marché du tourisme des cabarets et des
maisons de jeux largement alimenté par
les
États-Unis grande période de créativité
musicale c'est aussi l'époque de la
dictature de Baptista et des débuts de
la lutte
révolutionnaire
il y a TR versant dans le monde de la
salsa l'ensemble cubain les orchestres
de charanga et les de son ce sont les TR
format par Excell du monde de la
[Musique]
salsa
les années 50 sont très importantes pour
la musique cubaine c'est précisément
cette annéel que Enrique horin lance son
ta la engagnadora la
tresse à l'époque il jouait avec
l'orchestre América une charanga et il
était déjà proche de l'orchestre très
important qui se maintient aujourd'hui
et qui a eu un succès international
l'orchestre
Aragon l'orchestre Aragon est
fondamentalement un orchestre de Cha
mais dont la sonorité a été imitée dans
toute la Caraïbe et surtout en
Afrique en Afrique l'orchestre Aragon
est un symbole de la musique cubaine de
même que dans toute la
Caraïbe à partir du TA et des sonorités
des orchestresangas qui sont ces
orchestres piano violon et FL ils ont
développé le Danon ils ont chanté le son
le boléro et ils ont abordé de nombreux
genres de la musique cubaine qui ont été
imité par la suite suivi dans le monde
de la
salsa m
[Musique]
saler que va me Busa la bella salgo con
ella que va me Bua la bella salgo
[Musique]
con Buc la bella Salo con
ellaar la
bellao
cono con ella
est dans cette génération des années 50
il n'y a pas que des orchestres typiques
ou des charangas comme la
Aragon mais il y a aussi des ensembles
comme par exemple celui de Félix
chapottine qui est dans la lignée
d'arsenio
Rodriguez c'est-à-dire de l'ensemble
avec des cuivres et de plus c'est un
ensemble qui est le pont
ou l'un des ponts les plus directs vers
la salsa
[Musique]
d'aujourd'hui por eso en el
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
barrioachach
CUC
[Musique]
CUC er cucita
CUC cucita
[Musique]
cucaro cucarecita
cucarocita
cucón
en el
barrio
ratón ven conmigo a cortar laa
[Musique]
con
depuis 1961 Cuba est un pays
socialiste la créativité des musiciens
n'a pas cessé pour autant et la
population participe activement au fêtes
en plein air qu'elle soit spontané ou
organisé par le
gouvernement à Cuba la musique est
partout il suffit d'installer des
haut-parleurs dans la rue et
immédiatement les gens affluent pour
danser sur les tubes du
moment
depuis quelques années le carnaval d'été
a été supprimé faute de moyens malgré
cela et malgré la pénurie qui les frappe
les Cubains ne renonc jamais à faire la
[Musique]
fête
buo un año
[Musique]
peligroso
u
[Musique]
entonces
quelle langue étrange parle donc et
pourquoi branditil une brassée
d'herbe il s'inpire en fait ici de la
culte d'origineba et purifie le public
en nettoyant les mauvaises influence
avec ses herbes et en espergeant de
l'eau pour que s'en aille tout ce qui
est
mauvais
agua vamos a refrescar El ambientem
aguaagua Para que
agu
AG
agu oye yo quiero yo quiero pasear
agu cam no REC
agua que no le CO miedo al agua
Caballero
agua
elorev est
changuisero le CHANGUI est une forme
très ancienne du son guantanamero de la
zone de
Guantanamo elorev a pris les traditions
du CHANGUI et les a incorporé à sa
musique n'est pas seulement enraciné
dans les traditions du Changi il mélange
des traditions très différentes et il
les enrichit beaucoup à partir de tout
ce qu'il sait de tout ce qu'il
manipule toute cette culture qui prend
racine dans les religions afroocubaines
leur façon de jouer des tambours leur
rythme très spécifique leur comportement
gestes façon de chanter dont les
antécédents directs appartiennent à
cette musique afroocubaine qu'on trouve
encore aujourd'hui dans la Santeria ou
dans les cultes Palo ici à
Cuba
[Musique]
dans les années 60 celui qui jouit de la
basse avec R n'était rien moins que Ran
formel qui se sépare de l'orchestre d' r
en
1970 et forme son propre orchestre Los
Van qui est encore aujourd'hui l'un des
principaux orchestres du monde de la
salsa
actuellement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Cabo y
ampárame e con licencia yo me voy a
arrodillar otra vez pídele ampárame
arriba para el piso todo el mundo que le
pidea a él aos
ampárame así nada más cubano que yo sé
que ti fe a
ampárame qué dice
os ampárame som los
som la mano arriba para un somos
[Musique]
entre le public et les stars de la salsa
il n'existe à Cuba aucune barrière il
viv dans les mêmes quartiers et sei tous
les jours dans la
rue
197it une tournée
internationale première tournée il gagne
un gramis parce que c'était
extraordinaire quand Cho Valdes s'est
présenté avec un morceau appelé mess
noire qui a surpris tous les publics
nord-américains parce qu'il pensait que
la musique cubaine s'était arrêté au
moment où eux avaient cessé de
l'écouter et ça ne s'était pas passé
comme ça Cuba avait développé une
sonorité nouvelle pendant que toute
cette histoire de la Fania se passa
[Musique]
au
BAA tu
manera BAA tu
[Musique]
manera Baila a tu
manera
[Musique]
totalement dégagé des contraintes du
showbusiness la salsa cubaine continue à
évoluer de plus belle et s'enrichir de
nouvelles générations de jeunes
[Musique]
musiciens cependant Irak rapidement
change un peu de ligne ou maintient la
ligne jazistique mais s'incorpore à ce
type de sonorité le son mais avec des
concepts si proches du jazz qu'ils ont
été consacrés salcos de
fait en plus de ça
r jou de la flute avec Irak il est entré
par la suite et quand il est parti du
groupe
il a fondé son propre groupe en lui
donnant le nom de nouvelle génération
c'està-dire la nouvelle génération
d'Irak le groupe que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui à Cuba sous le nom de
Labanda et c'est peut-être l'un des
groupes les plus populaires au sein de
la Sala cubaine du
moment à l'époque o fait cette tournée
la f All Stars connaî ses heures de
gloire avec Johnny pach Charlie harl et
reetto tandis que de leur côté Tito poin
CIA Cruz Oscar de Léon et tant d'autres
contribu à porter la salsa sur la scène
[Musique]
internationale de cette grande vague
créative vont surgir de nouveaux groupes
comme la Sonora pa qui vient de Porto
Rico ou le groupe du panaméen Ruben
Blades
[Musique]
en marge du showbsiness les Cubains de
Cuba tombent pour un temps dans l'oubli
dans les pays industrialisés mais reste
au h parade des pays du tier monde
notamment sur le continent
[Musique]
africain ce n'est que grâce à
l'ouverture récente du pays que l'on
redécouvre la salsa cubaine en très peu
de temps elle supplante tous les autres
groupes qui entretemps se sont un peu
essoufflé au Japon on ne jour plus que
par n La Banda et en Europe les Cubains
sont
partout leur musique est nouvelle
inventive enthousiasmante et la façon de
la danser
[Musique]
aussi
pour danser la salsa il y a plusieurs
possibilités la danse classique en
couple est appelé
casino mais depuis les années 50 les
cors sont laissé aller à plus de
sensualité le despelot danse qui
consiste à exacerber la souplesse des
hanches et où les partenaires n'hésitent
pas à se coller l'un à l'autreit désor
fur chez les jeunes
générationhi honte de pratiquer ce qui
était encore appelé il y a 40 ans des
danses de
[__] les secousses et les ondulation du
bassin et de la poitrine sont devenu
naturels forme d'expression parmi
d'autres qui ne sont jamais interprété
comme vulgaires par les
[Musique]
cubain et comment voir dans ses sourires
radieux autre chose que le bonheur de
bouger son corps et d'affirmer sa
[Musique]
sensualité je crois qu'iraker ran formel
et même Adalberto font encore partie de
cette première génération de salcéros
Cubains qui ont créé ce mouvement ce
sonne ces sonorités ici à
Cuba mais par la suite apparaissent de
nouvelles générations de salceros et
parmi eux beaucoup sont diplômés des
écoles
ce sont des musiciens de ha niveau
technique qui dominent très bien les
techniques d'exécution de leurs
instruments et qui incorporent également
des concepts
harmoniques des concepts
d'instrumentation des concepts de timbre
très novateur grâce à la formation
académique qu'il
possède j'ai toujours eu depuis que je
suis tout petit le goût et l'affinité
pour la musique cubaine pour nos rythmes
grâce à mon père qui m'a inculqué tout
cela le son du piano surtout de la
musique qui se faisait à cette
époque il me mettait les disques les
enregistrements de Benny Moré et de
beaucoup
d'artistes alors bon j'étudié au
conservatoire et souvent je me mettais à
jouer du piano dans les classes de
musique et je faisais du désordre avec
le piano des des
scargass
[Musique]
azúcar
Preta s locura locura locura
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
locura
[Musique]
je suis son je suis sal je suis gu je
suis r Je suis tout ce qui se termine en
H ay qué
locura y qué es lo que cura eso
Pariente vaya
[Musique]
para
aquío
[Musique]
aquíoo
aquíero
o a
tieroo a
[Musique]
ti te repito que te dieron dónde fue que
te cogieron y Mira te repito la verdad
pero que mir
Go y vamos a bailar man para arriba
yANDO
[Applaudissements]
o
per
per ah F a ti TEER en Francia a ti te
cogier mir
[Musique]
repito dans le monde de la salsa CUB les
femmes sont rares sur scène conséquence
d'une certaine fallocratie dont la
société cubaine a encore du mal à se
dégager
pourtant des groupes féminins ont existé
et existent encore comme les célèbres
Ana kaona et le trio las
Deida de plus en plus de femmes osent
aujourd'hui s'affirmer comme sal s race
aussi bien en tant que chanteuse qu'en
tant que musicienne et
compositrice en ce moment nous les
femmes nous sommes en train de nous
émanciper et je crois que j'ai réussi
parce que je suis une femme excusez la
redondance mais bon à Cuba c'est
difficile les hommes sont très
matchistes et nous aussi nous sommes
matchistes j'ai une grande dose de
matchisme il me semble que c'est très
important et que c'est inutile d'aller
contre ça j'adore être aussi un petit
peu matchiste mais j'adore aussi dominer
c'est pour ça je crois que j'ai réussi
dans le milieu parce que les choses ne
s'obtiennent pas seulement avec des
impositions mais aussi parfois grâce à
des concessions et c'est aussi pour ça
que je me suis gagner le respect de mes
musiciens et le respect de
tous
yo
[Musique]
teo yo te
dir yo te
dir
all allá no VI de amor a
[Musique]
calmar
mais que pensez alors de toutes ces
chansons qui glorifient le macho comme
celle d'Isaac Delgado où il se venteent
d'avoir deux femmes en même
temps
FAM AR
s AR
s
AR
arri
arriba y abo arriba y abo arriba y abo
arriba y abajo todo el mundo como
diceo no tengo la
culpita ni tampoco la
culpona si con
una
Lao
[Musique]
equilibrio vengan calma mía señoras y
señores porque yo cumplo con mis deberes
por
eso de la no a la
maana me gust
no pero qué Linda qué Linda qué Linda
son qué Linda son cuando qui
vaya vaya
Colombia
[Musique]
pendant les années 70 la musique salsa
ét totalement rejeté par tous les
musiciens
cubains tu demandais à des musiciens
cubains qui fais ce qui aurait pu être
une Sala fabuleuse et il te
dis non je ne suis pas SALC je suis un
sonro
légitime
nous les sonos qui faisons de la salsa
comme on appelle ça aujourd'hui là-bas
nous pensons que la salsa est notre
sonne ilont salsa pour lui donner un nom
commercial pourtant dans les années 80
il y a eu un changement d'attitude on a
pensé que si un pays éta porteur des
valeurs légitimes de la salsa cétait
bien
Cuba quand nous faisons unea quand je
fais unea avec mon tri et bien je me
sens comme à l'intérieur de la salsa
mais avant tout nous nous sommes en
train de faire une
[Musique]
Guara cubain les paroles des chansons
ont toujours été importantes chronique
de la vie quotidienne souvent ironique
et toujours très proche des problèmes et
des préoccupations des gens leur refrain
passe dans le langage
populaire ainsi Adalberto Alvarez a
composé une chanson qui reflète
l'engouement des Cubains pour les cultes
afroocubains et que veux-tu qu'il te
donne demande le
chanteur la force de pouvoir en ver et
contre tout éprouvver de la joie de
[Musique]
vivre r le rap cette manière de chanter
a influencé beaucoup d'expressions dans
le monde et l'une d'ell a été la musique
sido la música
salsaicar chez
[Musique]
form
larugadaas
que tú quieres que te
[Musique]
den queú quieres que te
den y que tú quieres que te di es lo que
tú quieres que te queú quieres que Ch
para que te sientas
bienrica vinieron
nosotros
[Musique]
quedar
P a tu Santo otra
[Musique]
vez bueno familia esta juventud tan
Linda que tenemos esta tarde acá cómo se
sienten
ustedes lo oigo ah cómo se sienten
ustedes
bueno Caballero ahora vamos a preguntar
de nuevo P en el Caro y después cuando
yo le avise cómo se sienten ustedes yo
me siento bien cómo se sienten ustedes
oigan yo me siento ahora les toca cómo
se sienten
ustedes cómo se sienten
ustedesent cómo se sienten
ustedes
cómo se sienten
mujeres ahora Caballero si tú no
levantas la mano que se acaba esto si tú
no levantas la mano se acaba esto si tú
no
seelo para arriba
acabaca tuelo
Colorado acaba tú no sacas tu pañuelo mi
amigo si no sa tuyo qu se acaba el y si
la gente no me da un prinito qué se
acaba el y si la gente
no AC di la juventud ahora
acabaquito o si no Caballero
acaba la juventud
ahora juventud tan Linda juventud un
aplauso para Ed mismoero